Prof: What is the
significance of the real date on
Sancho's letter,
one wonders?
I don't have a ready answer for
it, but remember that it does
have the real date.
It is obviously the date when
Cervantes is writing this part
of the Quixote.
It may be a way of emphasizing
that the novel is dealing with
current history and situating
the novel chronology in a
specific way.
This is why the letter is given
a date.
It didn't have to have a date,
but I think that that is the
reason why.
I think that's the best answer
that I can give to the question
of why that letter,
what the significance--what
that date on the letter,
and what the significance of it
is.
But this is the sort of detail
that I want you to look for.
Remember my mantra:
details, details,
details.
Literature is made of specific
concrete details,
not of abstractions,
like philosophy,
and this is why it is important
to remember,
to notice details,
and to base your
interpretations on the details.
Now, as we move closer to the
end the Quixote I would
like to make some general
comments and revisit some of the
themes that I have touched upon
earlier,
as a way of summing up our
reading of this great classic
that we have been reading all
semester.
In the last lecture I talked
about the increasing presence of
Virgil and of his Aeneid,
and suggested that Cervantes is
hinting at the significant
responsibility that his
protagonist is assuming,
which is quite different from
that of the ancient hero,
but no less important:
to conquer himself,
to come to grips and control
his madness,
and to assimilate his new won
realization of the vanity of his
dreams and the futility of his
quest.
His task is to bring himself to
harmony with the world in which
he lives,
full of imperfections and
disappointments,
and to assume a resigned
attitude towards it and prepare
for his impending death.
If at the beginning of the
semester I quoted Lukács,
George Lukács,
the Hungarian critic,
to the effect that the
Quixote was the epic of a
world abandoned by God,
Don Quixote's epic task within
the novel is to cope with such a
world,
to conquer such a world,
as it were.
His is a very modern condition
in that sense,
but not necessarily a
despairing one.
This, I think,
is what the novel shows as the
hero begins his return home,
and this is why I'm asking you
to try to finish it.
Don Quixote's change is gradual
and it began with,
I think, Dulcinea's enchantment
by Sancho, the shock of seeing
this peasant woman as Dulcinea;
and it peaked,
I think, during the descent to
the cave of Montesinos,
as we mentioned.
I think that he will display,
or he is displaying now,
a deepened kind of wisdom,
nowhere more memorably than in
the counsel he gives Sancho,
as his squire is prepared to
take over the government of the
island of Barataria--
you remember that episode when
Don Quixote takes Sancho aside
and,
after telling him not to gloat
about his great fortune,
but to thank God,
that this happened to him
without his really even trying,
evincing, somewhat a little bit
of envy,
good old Don Quixote.
Here he takes him aside to give
him some counsel.
This passage of the
Quixote is one of the more
anthologized ones in the
Spanish-speaking world.
I know a judge in Puerto Rico
who has these pages framed in
gold in his office,
and he shows them proudly to
anyone who happens to be near.
They are wonderful--this
wonderful advice that Don
Quixote gives Sancho,
and there are obvious
philosophical and literary
sources to Don Quixote's wisdom,
and there are also obvious
critical statements that refer
to the current situation in
Spain and its empire,
particularly,
the counsel regarding the
corruption of people in power
and in government.
These are barbs at the
situation, at the Spanish
bureaucracy.
Don Quixote's advices have
bookish sources,
but they also sound deeply
felt, and also,
as if they were,
grounded in experience.
This is the knowledge of a
mature man, and Don Quixote is
more than a mature man;
he's an old man by the
standards of the age,
so he is in a position to
counsel Sancho,
who's younger and,
of course, his squire.
The counterparts to Don
Quixote's wisdom are Sancho's
proverbs,
which express a folksy kind of
astuteness and knowledge of
humankind,
and, as we have seen,
Sancho can spew proverbs at the
drop of a hat.
Proverbs have been taken to be
the accumulated wisdom of the
ages,
stored in the common memory of
mankind,
and were of great interest to
Renaissance thinkers,
who were keenly attracted by
language and the knowledge that
it contained,
both as a system of
communications,
that is, language as grammar,
and also for the contents of
the lore that it stored;
not only Latin and Greek,
the classics,
as the humanists were
interested and,
of course, as we know,
in the classics,
and in Latin,
and Greek, and Hebrew,
but also in the vernacular
languages in which they were
immersed.
They were very,
very interested in that.
And, in fact,
there is a whole science of the
study of proverbs whose name is,
in Spanish--I don't know if the
word exists in English--
paramiología,
the study of proverbs.
There seem to be many more in
Spanish than in English,
anyway;
I feel that way,
but probably because Spanish is
my native language.
But I remember summer nights at
the square in Salamanca,
a beautiful town square in
Salamanca,
sitting around with professors
of language,
and seeing who could say more
proverbs,
and then, also,
we invented the game that one
would say the first part of a
proverb and another one would
say the second part of another
one that had nothing to do with
it,
so it was a really great game
of proverbs.
Try it.
It's fun.
So what I'm saying is that
proverbs are very much a part of
the language,
and they are a kind of a
storehouse of wisdom.
This is the counterpart of Don
Quixote's more bookish kind of
knowledge.
The interest in grammar,
of course,
was that it was thought that
grammar and rhetoric could
reveal the very workings of the
human mind,
and this is why humanists were
interested in it.
So now, in the end,
Sancho's wisdom is not going to
be different from that of Don
Quixote.
And it is certainly not
inferior, and in practice proves
to be quite effective.
Of course, Don Quixote's advice
extends to Sancho's appearance,
mode of dress,
to clip his fingernails,
and what to wear on different
occasions,
how to have his wife behave so
that she won't show that she's
just a peasant,
and all of that.
That is the funny part of the
advice.
But Sancho's knowledge,
Sancho's wisdom is up to the
task.
Sancho's acumen is sufficient
for him to deal with the
challenges of government,
as it is for him to face the
challenges of his own life.
Sancho is endowed with natural
reason.
This is a medieval concept that
I have mentioned before,
that courses through the
Renaissance and reaches the
Enlightenment,
where it will be instrumental
in the elaboration of modern
ideas about democracy,
ideas that we all share today.
It is, ultimately,
as I have said several times,
a common Christian doctrine,
that we are all endowed by God
with enough intelligence to make
it in the world,
no matter what our station in
life or level of education.
But at the end of the episode,
unsuccessful through no fault
of his own, Sancho rues that he
was not born to be a governor,
he says.
He accepts the social order,
which was based,
in spite of what I've just said
about natural reason,
was based strictly on the
ideology that a person's social
station was determined by God,
and that it was best,
as Sancho says,
to stick to what you are and to
the condition into which you
were born.
This is a conflictive moment in
the novel,
but the fact is that he has
done very well as governor,
and only the deceptions of the
duke and his minions rob him of
his real achievements,
real achievements in this
fictional world in which he
accomplished them,
we must remember.
Now, in connection to this,
remember Auerbach's theory
about the birth of realism and
the sermo humilis,
that is, the common discourse
of Christianity.
So you can see that all of this
is connected,
but the contradiction,
of course, is that within the
society,
which is a society that is
crumbling,
as I have been saying,
this distinction,
these social distinctions,
are important.
They're crumbling because,
look, the most clever fellow in
this whole episode is the
steward,
who, after all,
is a servant,
and Sancho does very well as a
governor.
So this is the overall theme of
today's class,
has to be, that is,
that the social structures are
crumbling.
So we move to the island of
Barataria.
Let us begin by talking about
the name.
In the original,
Sancho refers to the island as
"í
;nsula,"
let me put it as small so you
can see the accent,
in lower case,
"í
;nsula."
Now, of course,
by this time,
the word for "island"
in Spanish was already the
current word,
which is
"isla,"
from the Latin.
In the Latin,
when you had two consonants
like that,
the tendency in the romance
language is for the second one
to absorb the first one,
so therefore,
from "í
;nsula"
you get
"isla,"
and in French you get
"île."
Now, that's a little bit of
philology.
So Sancho repeats
"í
;nsula,"
unaware that it is an archaic
word then for island,
that Don Quixote uses because
he has learned it reading the
romances of chivalry.
Something that you lose
completely in the translation is
the fact that Don Quixote,
whenever the issue of chivalry
arises,
or of Dulcinea,
lapses into a kind of archaic
Spanish;
this is not done in the
translation.
Meaning, he will say,
for instance,
"fermosa"
for "hermosa,"
which was by then already the
current Spanish word for
"beautiful."
"Hermosa,"
if you want a little more
philology,
comes from the Latin from
"forma,"
"formosa,"
"shapely,"
in how the island of
"Formosa."
Philology is fascinating.
So, whenever Don Quixote talks
about chivalric things,
he uses
"fablar"
for "hablar"
because,
by the sixteenth century,
the "f"
of the Latin had become a
silent "h."
So Sancho uses "í
;nsula,"
as the one,
he wants to rule an
"í
;nsula,"
an island,
and he's using this archaic
word.
So "ínsula
Barataria."
Because of this usage in the
Quixote,
the word "í
;nsula"
has a currency in Spanish now
and there is even a famous
journal in Madrid called
Ínsula,
after this archaic word used by
Don Quixote and Sancho.
Now, "Barataria."
Barataria--I can never find
the--here it is.
"Barataria"
comes from
"barato,"
"barato"
means "cheap."
So this would be
"cheap-island."
Both because of its low cost
and its shoddy fragile
construction,
it is like a stage set to
perform the play that the
steward has prepared.
It is cheap then also in the
sense that the island is not
real.
I think that a better
translation, if we were going to
translate everything,
would be something like
"Chintzy Island"
would be the name of it.
Of course, Sancho does not
pierce through the name,
to realize that this is not a
very promising name for his
kingdom to be ruling "cheap
island."
He doesn't know exactly--he
doesn't know at all what it
means, but this is what it
means,
"Barataria."
Now, let us begin by pointing
out the sources of the steward's
invention,
the practice of making someone
king for a day was common in
carnival celebrations throughout
Europe since the Middle Ages,
and further back to saturnalias.
The joke, that is,
the humor, was in seeing how a
low class dolt would act out his
role as a king,
or to have someone play the
role of someone from the lower
classes trying to act like a
king.
It could also be just a skit,
but part of the carnival
practice was to make somebody a
king for the day.
This involved,
in saturnalias,
and in these kinds of
carnivals, an inversion of
roles.
We have echoes of that in
today's secret societies here,
in fraternities,
when they have that day where
the pledges are in charge of the
brothers,
all of those things that I'm
sure you have heard about are
atavistic retentions of this
carnival type of ritual,
where you make someone a king
for a day.
In fact, in the 1950s there was
a TV show called Queen for a
Day,
I don't know if you ever heard
of it,
in which a common housewife was
crowned queen for the day in the
show,
and she got to rule over
people, and to have anything she
wanted,
and so forth.
Yes, television incorporated
some of these carnivalesque
practices.
Now, the practice extends to
other cultures beyond the
western tradition.
Besides, the practice of making
a stranger king and then
deposing him,
is one so prevalent that Sir
James Frazer--
I have mentioned him before but
you've got to remember his name,
Sir James Frazer,
F-R-A-Z-E-R--devoted many pages
of his classic The Golden
Bough to this practice.
The idea was to punish the
ruler for the perquisites that
he enjoyed while being king,
and for not having been able to
solve problems,
such as droughts and other
natural catastrophes.
We'll see this later,
when I quote Freud.
So the steward is basing his
elaborate prank on a traditional
routine, though he does take it
to an extreme.
This not just king for a day,
but for several days,
and it's consistent in this
expansion,
and this exaggeration with the
Baroque character of Part II.
The point is that the whole
thing is supposed to be a joke
at Sancho's expense,
and it is part of the merriment
at the duke and duchess's
palace.
It also part of the merriment
for the participants in this
whole charade,
they are acting it out as if
this were a carnival.
There are other traditional
elements in the episode,
traditional acts,
traditional scenes,
for instance,
the one in which Sancho passes
judgment on several cases that
come up before him.
It's a traditional one that
goes back even to the Bible--
King Solomon--and also in folk
traditions,
the traditions of riddles that
rulers,
or wise men,
are supposed to solve.
The tradition of oracles,
back to the Greeks,
and so Sancho solves several
complicated cases,
every single one of them coming
from folk tradition,
but hilarious at the same time,
probably because of it they are
hilarious.
For instance,
Sancho solves a case involving
an alleged rape.
This is the very funny episode
where the man is accused of
having raped this woman;
the man, furthermore,
is the lowest of the lowest;
presumably these are all people
acting out.
He's a hog herder, a pig keeper.
I mean, this is the lowest;
remember, in the first part,
when the keeper of pigs
arrives,
and even the mention of the
word "puerco"
in Spanish has to be followed
by "excuse me,"
"puerco"
for pig,
and he's supposed to have
forced himself on this woman,
and Sancho has to decide,
and he asks if the man gave her
a bag of money,
and when she's leaving,
he says, take it from her,
and she fights like an animal
so as not to give up the money,
and then, he says,
well if you had defended like
yourself like that there would
have been no rape.
But this is a case,
remember, that I mentioned this
in--
when I talked about the
prisoner of sex:
this is a case of
"fornicatio
simplex,"
a case of simple fornication.
The Inquisition and Spanish law
had classified fornication.
The Inquisition and its laws,
and all of that,
followed scholastic practice of
classifications very
Aristotelic,
so there was simple
fornication, and then qualified
fornication,
of which there were several
kinds depending on whether--
simple fornication is sex
between two people who are
unmarried and of different sex,
and then complex fornication
comes when the people are of the
same sex;
one is married,
both are married but to other
people, and so forth.
So this is a case of
fornicatio simplex that
Sancho, the judge,
is passing his sentence on;
it is one of the traditional
stories.
Now, then he has to--he is
presented with a very
complicated case about Clara
Perlerina,
"Clara,"
clear,
"Perlerina"
derived from "pearl,"
"clear pearl";
she's quite a pearl.
Remember, this is the young
woman, presumably,
in this completely made up
story within the made up story,
the usual receding sequence in
Cervantes who is half beautiful
and half horrible.
If you turn to your page 769:
"'I say then' quoth the
countryman,
'that this son of mine,
who is to be the bachelor,
fell in love,
in the same village with a
damsel called Clara Perlerina,
daughter of Andrés
Perlerino,
a very rich farmer;
and this name of Perlerino came
not to them by lineal,
or any other descent,
but because all of that race
are subject to the palsy;
and to mend the name,
they call them Perlerines;
though to say the truth,
the damsel is like any oriental
pearl, and, looked at on the
right side, seems a very flower
of the field;
but, on the left,
she is not quite so fair;
for, on that side,
she wants an eye,
which she lost by the
small-pox;
and, though the pits in her
face are many and deep,
her admirers say,
they are not pits,
but sepulchres,
wherein the hearts of her
lovers are buried.
She is so cleanly,
that, to prevent defiling her
face,
she carries her nose so crooked
up,
that it seems to be flying from
her mouth: and for all of that
she looks extremely well;
for she has a large mouth;
and, did she not lack half a
score or a dozen teeth and
grinders, she might pass,
and make a figure,
among ladies of the best
fashion.
I say nothing of her
lips...'"
And so on...
Sancho sees through all of
this, as something made up,
and refuses to grant this,
but this is a very interesting
figure,
because, I have mentioned in
the last class,
the figure of the monster who's
made up of contrasting features,
of opposing features.
In the case of Trifaldín
it was the black robe and the
white beard,
black and white,
and here, it is extreme beauty
on one half,
and on the other,
this horrendous face,
pockmark, and lacking an eye,
and all of that;
the two very opposites clashing
in one figure.
This is in reference to this
Baroqueness of Part II,
but also, to show Sancho's
sharp wit to see through this
prank that they are trying to
play on him within the prank
that he is already undergoing.
If you compare Clara to
Maritornes you see that
Maritornes is not that
symmetrical.
Maritornes is ugly from the top
down, and--whereas here,
we have a perfect symmetry,
as it were.
Now, you have to remember,
always, and I keep insisting on
this, this is all made up by the
steward who is the author of
this whole charade.
Now, the gist of the episode is
given by the steward himself,
when he says,
in page 798,781,
when he says:
"‘My lord governor,'
quoth the steward,
'speaks so well,
that I wonder to hear a man,
so void of learning as your
worship,
who, I believe,
cannot so much as read,
say such and so many things,
and all so sententious and
instructive,
and so far beyond all that
could be expected from your
worship's former understanding
by those who sent us,
and by us, who are come hither.
But every day produces new
things;
jests turn into earnest,
and jokers are joked
upon.'"
It is good to remember here,
and I'm going to repeat a quote
from that American hispanist,
Ruth El-Saffar,
that is very appropriate at
this point,
and I'll repeat it.
She wrote: "All of Part II
is based on the mistaken
assumption on the part of the
would-be,
all-controlling character
authors that they can deal with
the fictional character and
maintain at the same time a
distance which allows them never
to slip into that fictional
world with which they plan to
entertain themselves.
Like Sansón,
they are trapped from two
directions,
they are controlled to some
extent from within their play by
the very characters whom they
intend to manipulate,
and from without by an author
of whom they are unaware but
whose will and whose hand all
that they do is contrived."
And this is the case here,
of course,
of the steward who is himself
acknowledging that the things
have turned out not quite the
way that he had planned it,
that he and the duke and
duchess had planned it,
which was, of course,
to have fun at the expense of
Sancho,
but Sancho turns out,
on the contrary,
to be quite a good governor,
and so the tables are turned.
This is another one of these
inversions that are happening
regularly in Part II of the
Quixote.
It is also good to notice that
the steward is aware of both of
his construction of this whole
episode and of its sort of
collapse.
Now, in a larger sense,
Barataria has to do with the
breakdown of aristocratic
authority and the emergence of
the common man as potential
ruler.
Sancho proves to be wise,
beyond all expectations,
and in spite of all of the
pranks that he and his master
endure.
As with Clavileño,
the episode that we discussed
in the last class,
his dignity remains untouched,
and the mockers are the ones
who are mocked.
Sancho became a good governor;
this is this the ironic result,
a counter intuitive resolution
that thwarts the designs of the
duke and duchess and that
undermines the authorial
intentions of the steward who
obviously wanted Sancho to
provide the humor by acting
stupid,
and this is,
in part, and this is something
that I have not mentioned
before,
but that is easy to figure out,
these are misreadings of Part
I,
on the part of characters in
Part II.
They assume that the characters
are going to act in a certain
way,
by the way they have
interpreted Part I,
and they have interpreted Part
I with Sancho as a buffoon,
Sancho as just a comic
character, which is the way that
Avellaneda interpreted Sancho,
if we remember the class on
Avellaneda,
so it's good to keep this in
mind, that these are misreadings
on the part of the steward,
on the part of the duke and
duchess,
who expect Don Quixote and
Sancho to act in a certain way,
so these are mistakes in the
reading.
Now, besides the folkloric
sources that I have mentioned of
Barataria, the background is
also literary and philosophical.
It is a self contained society,
presumably to be well run.
This is the humanistic theme of
utopia.
Going back to Thomas
More--remember,
I have been mentioning all
along the names of important
Renaissance figures that you
must--
that you should remember.
Of course, it's easy for you to
just check it out in Wikipedia.
More was the author of
Utopia,
the book of the same name,
just published in 1516,
also, Tommaso Campanella,
1568-1639,
who published City of the
Sun in 1602,
which was also a utopia.
This is the idea that the
perfect society can be
established on this earth
following a rational design.
The concept goes back,
of course, to Plato's
Republic,
and to all of the treatises
that begin to appear in the
Renaissance about the art of
government,
including, of course,
Machiavelli's The
Prince,
that I have mentioned several
times here.
The Prince is also in
the background here,
because Sancho is trying to act
like the perfect prince,
like the perfect ruler,
and hence Machiavelli's The
Prince is in the background
of this episode.
So see how many important
Renaissance thinkers are behind
in this episode.
But what does it mean?
I mean, utopia--these utopias,
by the way,
are the origin of modern
political systems,
or the idea that with the
political system you can create
or improve a society to make it
like a utopia.
In the eighteenth century,
particularly,
these ideas will become a
reality and they have become,
of course, as we know,
nightmares in the twentieth
century,
some of these utopias have
turned out to be quite the
opposite,
to the point that you've had to
have walls to keep the people
inside of them.
But--so this is the idea that
you can rationally create a
perfect society,
and so, what is it here in this
episode of the Quixote?
Is it a parody of these notions
of utopia?
I mean, Barataria is a mock
utopia, of course,
with a fake king,
and it all ends in a great
catastrophe.
Is it a parody showing the
futility of such attempts?
It could be.
I think that the episode is
important enough and given
enough relevance in the book to
invite interpretations of this
kind.
Now, Barataria,
being an island,
reflects other things,
three of them.
For instance,
one, the idea of self
containment and self
sufficiency,
of roundness,
as is it were,
and at one point it is referred
to as
"redonda,"
round,
the island is round,
and islands tend to be self
contained because,
of course, they're surrounded
by water.
Two, I think,
Barataria also reflects the
recently discovered islands of
the Caribbean,
recently, you know,
late fifteenth century,
early sixteenth century,
where the Spaniards attempted
to create societies almost from
the ground up,
in Hispaniola and in Cuba,
and also the wished for,
but never reached,
islands of the classical
tradition.
These were called,
I'm going to put it in English,
"ante-islands,"
this is where you get the name
for "Antilles,"
the Antilles,
comes from those "before
islands,"
those islands;
these were fugitive islands,
that is,
islands that you saw in the
distance,
and you were supposed to arrive
at,
and like the oasis in the
desert, as you came closer,
they got further and further
away, suggesting that these were
islands that you wanted to
reach,
and that perhaps you would find
utopia,
or an oasis, or something.
Of course, on this level,
the island has that quality of
elusiveness that one would
associate with Atlantis.
So, if you can see,
the depth of this episode in
the Quixote by dint of
the many sources,
ideas and books that it has
behind it.
Now, Freud mentions this
episode in Totem and
Taboo, and his take on this
episode is very instructive.
Now, remember,
I mentioned,
I think in an earlier class,
that Freud was a devoted reader
of Cervantes,
and that as an adolescent he
created a Cervantes club with
several friends to read
Cervantes and discuss it,
and so forth,
and they even gave themselves
names from characters in some of
The Exemplary Stories,
and all of that.
Now, as you will see,
Freud interprets this episode
by sort of reducing it to his
own system, of course,
and thinkers tend to do that.
Freud examines the suffering a
king must undergo to pay for his
exalted position in the
traditions that I have already
mentioned--in Frazer,
remember.
To Freud, this is played out
chiefly in the hilarious scene
where Sancho is denied food.
Freud is drawing an analogy
between certain neurosis and the
behavior of primitives,
focusing on the ambivalent
attitude towards kings and its
analog in their relationships of
children to their fathers;
people to the king,
children to fathers.
He says--I quote:
"Here the importance of a
particular person is
extraordinarily heightened,
and his omnipotence is raised
to the improbable in order to
make it easier to attribute to
him the responsibility for
everything painful that happens
to a patient.
Savages really do not act
differently towards their rulers
when they ascribe to them power
over rain and shine,
wind and weather,
and then dethrone or kill them
because nature has disappointed
their expectation of a good hunt
or a ripe harvest."
Of course, you can see the
figure of the father,
the omnipotent father,
and hence, all of the theories
Freud had about the Oedipal
complex,
and all of that. He goes on:
"Thus, also the taboo
ceremonial of kings is nominally
an expression of the highest
veneration [because the relation
to the father is an ambiguous
one,
of veneration and hostility]
and a means of guarding them.
Actually, it is the punishment
for their elevation,
the revenge which their
subjects take upon them.
The experiences which Cervantes
makes Sancho Panza undergo as
governor of his island have
evidently made him recognize
this interpretation of courtly
ceremonial as the only correct
one.
It is very possible that this
point would be corroborated if
we could induce kings and rulers
of today to express themselves
on the point."
Here, Freud,
of course, is being ironic:
let's ask kings and rulers
today if they want to undergo
this kind of process.
Then, he goes on,
to make the unavoidable
comparison with the Christian
myth.
He goes: "Why the
emotional attitude towards
rulers should contain such a
strong unconscious share of
hostility is a very interesting
problem.
We have already referred to the
infantile father complex.
We may add that an
investigation of the early
history of kingship would bring
the decisive explanations.
Frazer, [Sir James Frazer,
whom I mentioned]
has an impressive discussion of
the theory that the first kings
were strangers,
who, after a short reign,
were destined to be sacrificed
at solemn festivals as
representatives of their deity,
but Frazer himself does not
consider these facts all
together convincing.
Christian myths are said to
have been still influenced by
the after effects of this
evolution of kings."
Look at the idea of the slaying
of Jesus Christ,
the king of the Jews and so
forth.
But you can see how this
illuminates what is going on in
Barataria with Sancho Panza,
how Freud's take on this help
us understand better the
mechanisms.
Now, this is part of the
traditional background,
but also, of course,
the nightmare of finally
getting what you crave,
and not being able to quite get
your hands on it.
You know, those wish
fulfillment dreams,
where you have that cake--let's
put it in those terms and not
give it an erotic twist--
that pie or something that you
want,
and that you're about to get,
and you don't quite get;
but also the disappointment of
achieving things.
Things are never quite that we
imagined or desired,
but they say,
be careful of what you wish,
because you may get it,
and once you get it,
it may turn out to be not
exactly what you expected,
and there is something of that
here, too.
This is the strong
desengaño element,
of these episodes on this
island.
The scene that so fascinated
Freud, in which Pedro Recio de
Agüero--that's a name that
we might want to also unpack.
This is the doctor,
the very funny doctor,
who keeps saying,
"No, no,
no, you can't eat that;
that's the worst you can eat!
No, no, no, you cannot eat
that."
"Recio"
means "hard."
Hard."
"Me llevas
recio,"
you're treating me hard,
you say in Spanish,
"de
Agüero."
It can be a last name,
but
"agüero"
means "omen."
"Omen";
"mal aguero,"
a bad omen, and he is a
"natural de
Tirteafuera."
That's the name of the town he
comes from;
it means "keep you
out";
this is what it means,
keep you out.
When I was a kid,
and you wanted to get rid of a
kid,
an adult would tell him,
"Go see so-and-so and ask
her to give you some
tenteallá,
keep you there.
Tell her to give you some
tenteallá,
keep you there."
So Tirteafuera is more or less
like that.
This is quite a remarkable
character, this doctor.
This is a very
Molière-like scene.
If you've read Molière,
in Molière there is
always,
this hilarious criticism of
doctors,
who are always going around
with a huge enema trying to give
an enema to somebody and that
sort of thing,
or whenever the situation is
difficult,
they begin declining Latin
nouns and verbs,
because, of course,
the idea is to know Latin well
to be able to read the sources,
because medicine was at this
point still very scholastic,
based on all of this on
sources, on written sources,
more than on experience.
Some of it was on experience.
See, part of the Baroque is the
clash between the scholastic
traditional knowledge that does
not stand up to actual
experience,
and this is why the critique of
medicine is so important and so
relevant.
It's not just funny,
because this scene is
hilarious,
it's very, very funny,
but it's also very significant
because it reflects a condition
of the time.
Now, the end of Sancho's
government is catastrophic,
as you know,
and it's one episode in which
like the fall from the horse,
where the horse explodes,
he may have been injured.
Now, Barataria is also like a
laboratory experience on
fiction, on fiction making.
How does one create a fictional
world coherent within itself.
All fiction,
all novels, or stories,
are the creation of a coherent
world within itself,
one that is round,
as it were.
The fiction obviously gets out
of hand of the steward,
and he cannot quite stand
outside of it,
like a puppeteer,
and this is parallel to Master
Peter and his puppet show,
and perfection,
of course, of this fictional
world cannot be quite achieved,
and this is parallel to,
of course,
Cervantes's situation
vis-à-vis the
Quixote.
One way that I imagine,
it is, I mean if this is the
world of fiction,
the creator,
the steward,
is here trying to control it,
but he winds up here,
and once he is inside,
he does not have the all
encompassing perspective,
and he has all of the problems
that the characters he has
created have.
So that is the--this is where
the irony comes in and this is
where--
but on the other hand,
this effort to create,
this self contained coherent
fiction anticipates...
What?
Macondo!
The fictional village in One
Hundred Years of Solitidue;
Comala, the fictional village
in Rulfo's Pedro
Páramo--
if you're not aware of this
Rulfo, Juan Rulfo,
the great Mexican writer,
and his novel that I--
Pedro Páramo.
So, from the idea of utopia,
to also to the idea of creating
a fictional world,
you see the connection?
This is all behind the island
of Barataria.
Now, we are going to talk next,
in the next class,
about Altisidora,
this mock Dido that I hope you
are reading,
and also about Dueña
Rodríguez;
this is the one whose daughter
is impregnated,
and whose boyfriend refuses to
marry her and they don't put
pressure on him because he's the
son of the peasant who lends
money to the duke and duchess.
She's a very interesting
character;
she's the one who reveals the
physical defects of the duchess
and of Altisidora.
What are the physical defects
of these women?
The duchess,
who is sort of the beautiful
huntress and all of that,
apparently has some sores on
her legs that--
from which some liquid flows,
and Altisidora has bad breath.
This beautiful Altisidora,
who sings,
and all of that,
Dueña Rodríguez,
with great resentment,
says she has "un
aliento cansado,"
a tired breath,
so she has that.
These are defects that we would
not have found in the idealized
women of Part I,
and so this is significant
about Dueña
Rodríguez and the things
that she reveals.
But I want to finish by talking
about Don Quixote and Sancho,
the pair, because I came across
two recent articles on the two
of them as a pair that I want to
sort of summarize for you.
One is by Antonio
Carreño Rodríguez.
I emphasize the "rs"
and the
"eñes."
And Antonio Carreño
talks about the influence of Don
Quixote and Sancho on modern
comedy pairs,
such as Abbott and Costello,
Oliver and Hardy,
and even takes it all the way
up to characters in Seinfeld,
a show that I have to confess I
have never in my life seen,
but he has a picture here,
of characters from that show,
that apparently show a decided
influence from Don Quixote and
Sancho.
He also gives the folkloric
background of these pairs,
going back to the Middle Ages,
and projected then forward on
to the present.
I mean, Abbott and Costello,
one is fat, the straight man,
and then the other--you can
see, immediately the moment I
mentioned it,
yes!
This is Don Quixote and Sancho
in film.
The other is an article by my
friend Edwin Williamson,
who's a distinguished Oxford
hispanist and it has to do with
what it terms the power struggle
between Don Quixote and Sancho,
which is resolved ultimately in
favor of the squire,
because Don Quixote is having
to beg him to please give
himself the lashes necessary to
disenchant Dulcinea.
He mentions four episodes:
the fulling hammers,
when Don Quixote hits him over
the head;
and the enchanted Dulcinea,
when there is an inversion of
roles,
and Sancho is now the one
creating the chivalric kind of
reality out of normal every day
life;
Merlin's prophecy,
when he states that it is
Sancho who must give himself the
lashes on his behind to
disenchant Dulcinea,
which then makes Don Quixote
dependent on Sancho;
and finally,
a chapter that you--an episode
you may not have read yet in
chapter LX,
the fight between the two of
them, when Don Quixote tries to
force Sancho to give himself
lashes and takes his clothes off
to give him the lashes,
and Sancho wrestles Don Quixote
to the ground,
and puts his knee on his chest,
and says that he will not do
that.
Williamson gives and
appropriately political reading
to this power struggle,
with which I agree.
I think he's unduly harsh about
the end, when he says that
Sancho is being totally cynical,
even at Don Quixote's deathbed.
I think that Williamson went a
little bit too far there,
but I want to,
in conclusion,
today to read you his
conclusion,
because it is very much in tune
with what I have been saying
about Barataria and the rise of
the common man to a position of
government:
"Cervantes,
moreover [says Williamson]
was not unaware of the wider
political dimension of the power
struggle that he had first
adumbrated as far back as the
fulling mills [fulling hammers]
episode in Part I.
In the final crisis,
when the knight has been forced
to the ground by his squire,
Sancho's defiant assertion,
'Ayúdome a mí,
que soy mi señor,'
'I help myself because I am my
own master,' inevitably carries
political resonances,
for it implies a conscious
rejection of the traditional
basis of authority and status
and portends the emergence of a
different world,
a world that Cervantes himself
must have imagined with
disquiet,
if not with dread.
Thus, at the heart of the
Quixote there is an
intriguing irony.
Cervantes may well have started
out on his adventure of writing
with the purely literary aim of
discrediting the
máquina mal
fundada of the chivalric
romances but by a series of
logical steps arising from the
interaction of master and
servant he was lead to undermine
the principle hierarchy that was
the cornerstone of the ideology
of his day."
We will continue with this and
other themes in the next class.